jean-marc pékin confirme donc son
activité est reparti et terminera
l'année sur une croissance positive de
1% alors cette question pourquoi un tel
rebond est aussi vite alors c'est vrai
que beaucoup de gouvernements
occidentaux est venu de chine est
aujourd'hui et bien cette deuxième vague
enfonce encore plus l'activité en
occident en gros l'europe va perdre en
moyenne 10% de pipe 10% de richesse
c'est la perte que la france va subir
c'est du moins la prévision établie par
le ministère de l'économie ça représente
entre 500 et 800 milliards d'euros de
pertes sur l'ensemble des richesses
créées l'allemagne devrait limiter les
dégâts la grande bretagne elle va perdre
davantage aux états unis au canada on le
sait qu on devrait être à -1 4% alors
vous avez raison la chine dans tout ça
s'en sort plutôt bien alors pourquoi
eh bien d'abord parce que le virus a
démarré beaucoup plus tôt puisqu'il est
parti de là bas trois ou quatre mois
avant d'arriver en occident le régime
chinois c'est la deuxième raison a quand
même l'autorité de mettre sous cloche
beaucoup de populations et dès que le
feu reprend dans un an dans une partie
de la population et bien on enferme les
gens et puis croyez moi ça ne rigole pas
donc confinement absolue même les
commerçants même les les populations
n'ont pas le droit à même de sortir de
chez eux pour aller faire leurs courses
et puis la troisième raison est bien on
aurait déjà commencé à china a vacciné
environ 15 millions de chinois je parle
au conditionnel parce que on n'est pas
très sûr de la fiabilité de toutes ces
statistiques chinoises notamment su
concernant le vaccin
il ya beaucoup de flou sur sa
faisabilité et sur l'application est le
miracle chinois quand même temps est-ce
qu'il va durer sur vous et vous savez
les chinois entré 5 % vous le disiez
très bien au troisième trimestre de
cette année ce qui est assez remarquable
ça va sans doute s'amplifier jusqu'à 8
9% sur l'année 2021
c'est le miracle auquel ils sont
habitués depuis 15 ans puisque sur
pratiquement une croissance à deux
chiffres alors les occidentaux qui
travaille avec la chine ont repris bien
sur leur marché dans l'agroalimentaire
les vignerons de bordeaux ont retrouvé
au 2019 dans l'industrie automobile les
usines se sont remises à retourner c'est
notamment le cas de peugeot
parce que maintenant depuis trop quatre
mois les industries but lucho si lvmh
gucci hermès ni même les offres
italiennes sont plutôt repartis très
fort sur pékin sur shanghai rattrape en
usine en asie là les chiffres qui
étaient les leurs avant alors les
autorités chinoises ont remis les
salariés au travail assez rapidement les
consommateurs se sont rués dans les
magasins elle puis j'irai même plus loin
la chine est en train de renouer avec le
grand commerce international
ce week-end il s'est passé quelque chose
d'assez exceptionnel puisque la chine
avec 14 autres pays en asie a signé sans
doute le plus grand accord de libre
échange
on n'est jamais signé dans le monde
puisqu'on a installé un marché commun
qui est valable pour plus de 2 milliards
de consommateurs le seul pays d'asie
exclus de cette zone de libre échange de
ces l'inde mais c'est une zone de libre
échange qui va évidemment profiter et
d'abord aux chinois est ce que le rebond
chinois va profiter aux occidentaux aux
européens notamment en théorie la
réponse est oui à condition que les
transports redémarre ce qui est quand
même pas le cas conditions des économies
occidentales puisse redémarrer avec un
peu d'oxygène la plupart des accords
commerciaux n'ont pas été dénoncés mais
ils n'ont pas été repris aurait appliqué
le seul problème va être politique
politiques parce que je pense qu'on va
quand même assister un repliement des
économies en place sur le modèle
américain qui avait lancé par donald
trump
je pense pas que joe biden change
beaucoup l'album de ce côté là parce que
cette crise épidémique a montré au monde
entier à quel point nous étions parfois
dépendant de la chine mais elle a montré
aussi en quoi la chine n'avait pas
respecté les règles de l'om c'est au
début des années 2000
pékin a beaucoup profité de l'ouverture
sur l'étranger joe byden d'ailleurs qui
avait participé à cette négociation l'a
confirmé il ya quelques temps ils les
chinois auraient dû renvoyer l'ascenseur
en ouvrant leur propre marché une ne
l'ont pas fait ils ne l'ont pas fait
donc il va sans doute il falloir
remettre un certain nombre de ports du
la leur que va faire l'europe dans cette
affaire point c'est dans ce bras de fer
les états unis et la chine que va faire
l'europe actuellement on n'en sait pas
grand chose puisque l'europe a besoin
des marchés chinois elle a besoin de
l'argent chinois aussi bien sûr or la
chine est la démarche est elle a de
l'argent dans ce cas on peut imaginer
que les regards se tournent davantage
vers l'est ils ne se sont tournées
jusqu'à maintenant un certain experts et
observateurs prétendent que le courant
n'avait russe aura été inventé pour
faire les affaires de la chine ils vont
quand même très loin dans leurs propos
non je pense que vous avez raison
yann permet de le dire parce que pk a
besoin d'une économie mondiale forte ce
qui perturbe les entreprises chinoises
c'est aussi que les occidentaux h elle
n'achète plus grand chose en chine va
reconstituer ces courants d'achat donc
pékin a besoin d'un monde qui serait
plutôt en bon état mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que la chine à un projet politique
le projet politique c'est d'être la
première puissance mondiale et qu'une
pandémie comme celle ci rend service pas
au peuple chinois mais à ses dirigeants
si loin des cieux ça assure leur
suprématie
et ça a sur le fait que la chine peut
devenir effectivement dans quelques
années
la première puissance mondiale et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui motivait toute la
politique étrangère des états unis et
notamment de deux autres merci jean marc
sylvestre pour cet éclairage je rappelle
que vous êtes éditorialiste économique